[Music]
if you're a TV junkie like me you're
gonna be very excited about this the new
season of house of cards premiered last
week on Netflix I love house of cards
it's a guilty pleasure yeah it really is
fun I can't wait to dive into season
four ah I'm sorry who just said ha tis I
who just said ha ha and I'll say it
again ah okay why are you saying ha
because you're pitiful house of cards
will soon topple from the howling winds
of another much better show okay I think
we all know what show you referring to
the show about a power-hungry clan
ruthlessly fighting for control of their
kingdom yes no like I said that's the
one thing can you feel the chill in the
air Conan something is coming and it
starts with a W we now yeah winter is
coming
yeah winter no I'm speaking of wall
burgers Wahlburgers is the reality show
about the burger joint owned by Mark
Wahlberg's family hi the very same I
can't get enough of that show oh my god
let me see that show is that show any
good this is any good it is every good
each episode is as juicy as the burgers
they serve okay help me out what happens
on the show well first of all as the
name of the program would suggest the
plot revolves mostly around Wahlberg's
and hamburgers all right well you just
told me but the magic doesn't end there
sometimes there is unrest among the
Wahlberg's and Wahlberg is pitted
against Wahlberg in a battle of Walberg
all right okay that just I'm sorry it
doesn't sound like my cup of tea oh
really
maybe this will change your mind just
listen to this episode recap I copied
down from the Internet
mark pledges to make a super bowl burger
for the New England Patriots
however some members of the team have
their old ideas about the type of burger
wow that sounds pretty awesome at worst
okay whatever we'll check it out one
last question why are you dressed like
that
oh I dressed this way whenever I go to a
sex party and I just happened to be
going to a sex party right after this
taping all right well okay that's your
business I guess burgers returning March
night on A&E
[Applause]
[Applause]
you